what's going on guys this is rob and we
are back with kane the conqueror now one
thing i do want to say we will do
umbrella academy part three i'm probably
going to release that on friday just
because the hotel oblivion is a really
difficult story to follow um because
gerard way just wrote it in a really
complicated way uh so i need to read it
a couple times in order to be able to
make a video on it
that's how complicated it is it's it's
kind of nuts uh but as you guys know
with cane the conqueror volume one this
story largely tells
kind of the origin of kang but but not
really that's kind of the difficulty of
kang is that it's difficult to know
exactly where he starts the origin that
we got here is that he was basically
just a younger kid who existed in the
31st century and was plucked out of time
by an older version of himself and that
basically that older version wanted to
ensure that king the conqueror that he
would actually be successful in terms of
his various campaigns and whatnot and
the only way to do that was to rid his
younger self of what he saw as weakness
so that by the time his younger self
became him
that it would basically allow him to
become more capable right he would
actually be rid of all those different
weaknesses that cost him various battles
and things along those lines uh however
there will be a major player that will
appear here and by and large the rest of
the story will basically proceed by
giving that person a new origin story
which is kind of cool because it looks
like they're doing it largely for the
mcu so as you guys know in the last
video that we did you essentially had
younger king right nathaniel richards
we'll just kind of call him that so we
can differentiate between the two
technically both versions of king are
nathaniel but it just makes it easier to
differentiate between which characters
we're talking about uh that nathaniel
had essentially escaped what was the
destruction or a meteor crashing into
earth and essentially ending the age of
the dinosaurs and then suddenly popped
up here in ancient egypt now what this
does is this takes place during the era
of what is essentially rama tut now
that's where things get a little murky
because when he shows up here it's
essentially a giant battle taking place
now this battle is between ramu tut and
somebody else who we'll talk about here
in a little bit but on this battlefield
is effectively a moon knight now one of
the reasons why colin kelly is able to
pull this off is because as you guys
know just from the history of moon
knight and marvel comics it wasn't
really until mark spector was taken to
the statue of konshu that the world got
its first moon knight over the years and
really when i say over the years i mean
more recently in marvel comics that's
been changed right it's kind of been a
big retcon to essentially say there have
been different avatars of konshu on
earth in the form of a moon knight that
came before mark spector and it's not
uncommon for marvel to do that for years
for example danny rand was the only iron
fist and then we got orson randall who
was the iron fist before danny rand and
there were a whole bunch of iron fists
before orson randall it had just gone on
that way the idea of there being moon
nights that took place or existed before
march spectre that was largely the
result of jason aaron and his run on
avengers specifically with avengers 1
million so basically this idea that
there was an avengers team that existed
1 million years before the modern era it
was largely composed of big heavy
hitters so like odin the original
phoenix force as it existed on earth the
first star brand the first iron fist the
first black panther different things
along those lines just uh kind of giving
us these different stories sometimes it
works sometimes it doesn't when it comes
to moon knight what you get here is
basically this version that pops up now
there isn't a whole lot of explanation
given here initially instead what ends
up happening is that this person is told
or at least nathaniel is told by this
moon knight you are called by the moon
and initially when nathaniel chases this
moon knight down trying to figure out
who they are or where they're going or
how all this is working that the only
thing he's really told is that the voice
of the night speaks only truth a hero
from beyond time comes soon from the sky
to restore the ancient ways and in the
pretenders reign now this is one of the
things that we have to talk about here
is the nature of rama tut and why it is
that this version of moon knight differs
from mark specter so when it comes to
ramatat one of the things that we've
talked about before is that king the
conqueror in his initial attempt for
conquest had gone all the way back to
ancient egypt and basically seized
control and because of the fact that he
had come from the 31st century as has
been stated by different people and in
different ways that sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from magic and so cain the conqueror is
showing up here with the dance
technology as far as the ancient
egyptians were concerned he was a god
right they were like this guy's just
capable of incredible things this is
insane right obviously this person is a
god now pharaohs in the time of ancient
egypt were largely considered to be
avatars of god of specifically raw or
other other individuals on earth but
they were considered divine in nature
and so because of that king kind of fit
very nicely into how egyptians perceived
people uh specifically pharaohs and the
idea of magic and divine powers and so
that's why he sees control here now one
of the things to know is that konchu and
the various gods that existed had long
since existed here by and large khanshu
doesn't really care what goes on on
earth he's got his own scheme and his
own motivation one of the things that's
been recently established especially
during um oh my god jeff lemire's run on
uh on moon night is that konchu seeks to
basically find a vessel for himself to
basically rule the world hence the
reason why he had manipulated mark
spector and his disassociative identity
disorder in order to hollow him out
quote unquote and turn him into a vessel
that khanshu could inhabit and then rule
the world so kanchu and the various
other egyptian gods don't necessarily
concern themselves with the idea that
like king the conquerors come from the
future to the past in order to rule
ancient egypt but one of the other
things to notice here is that this
version of moon knight holy believes in
what kanchu told them and not to sound
too brusque about it but the reason why
is because they just don't know any
better by the time mark specter had
become moon knight people were more
intelligent they were more capable and
they were more aware of how the world
exists so the idea of gods and things
like that had largely fallen away this
takes place during that era to a degree
before the third celestial host where
you basically had the celestial showing
up and telling the various gods of earth
not to intervene in the affairs of
mortal men they kind of follow the falls
during that that bit of a murky period
we can largely assume that maybe that's
already happened but whatever it is the
influence of gods and goddesses on
humanity still holds strong and that's
why this person who became moon knight
hears the voice of konchu and takes it
as an absolute truth because by the time
mark specter came around in the 20th
century the idea of people believing in
gods sure it was there but they didn't
believe it with the same veracity right
they didn't believe it with the same
absolute belief system it was like
people believed in the idea of god
because they were more afraid of the
consequences of not believing than the
actual benefit of believing if there is
one and so as the two of them talk when
it comes to nathaniel remember he knows
the entire history of earth and so what
he says is he says far be it for me to
argue with my savior but ramatat isn't
someone you can just hope to overthrow
trust me i've studied him for years and
the response to this person is he's
enslaved the entirety of creation now as
somebody who's never left egypt as far
as they're concerned egypt is all of
creation and the the influence of of
rahmatut just stretches into infinity
now of course that's not the case and
nathaniel says it's only really egypt
but like that's plenty of stuff to rule
he says it's his war machine against my
broken suit of armor i'm sorry lady but
i'm not the hero that you're looking for
you're thinking of reed richards now the
reason why this matters and i love that
colin kelly did this is because in the
original story when rahmatut first
appeared in in marvel comics the
fantastic four traveled back to egypt
defeated ramat and forced him to travel
back to his timeline right they defeated
that version of king now again as we
discussed along the way back to his
timeline he ended up in the true limbo
became a mortise and then there's kind
of a splinter timeline where he ended up
going back and becoming king but the the
the reality here is that what you're
doing or at least what colin kelly's
doing is he's basically keeping the
continuity of the history of rama tut
intact but adding to it which is a
really cool thing that's a pretty
beneficial thing and a very important
thing but what goes on here is
ultimately nathaniel is taken to the
temple of konshu and is basically told
like talk to talk to kanchu itself and
find out if there's any real truth here
the reality though is that nathanael
doesn't really believe in gods i mean he
knows that they've existed but they're
not all powerful beings they don't
really exist in the capacity the way
that this this moon knight believes they
do that they are just people that are
out there and they can be killed and so
as a result of that nathaniel really
views gods as more of just really
powerful beings as opposed to these
divine individuals beyond the
understanding of humanity and with a
power that just simply simply can't be
matched the only real god that exists
out there in marvel comics in that
capacity is the one above all everybody
else can just be killed it just takes
differing levels of power to do it the
living tribunal was killed by the
beyonders the other cosmic entities as
well and the different cosmic entities
have been destroyed by different beings
depending on what era of comics you're
talking about if you're looking at al
ewing's ultimates that the uh that
eternity was basically defeated and not
really killed but overpowered by like
the first firmament right the sentience
of the first universe so it gets a
little meta and it gets a little wonky
but as the two of them continue talking
what ends up going on is that this
person reveals their identity to
nathaniel richards and we end up finding
out this moon knight is actually ravana
rinslayer now here's the thing to
understand here and this is why i say
from this point going forward the entire
history of ravana red slayer is going to
be completely rewritten or at least her
origin is going to be completely
rewritten the original origin of ravana
rimslayer is she's from the 40th century
and that you ended up having a time
where kane the conqueror had arrived
there but ultimately spared the place
because he was in love with her and then
it was a kind of love-hate relationship
where they loved each other then they
hated each other she killed him a couple
times they were just one of those things
there was literally a point where she
resurrected him just to kill him it was
it's kind of nuts right it was that
level of hate and disdain but it was
very much a love hate if anything a
passionate relationship between the two
what it looks like colin kelly's doing
is reworking the entirety of that by
introducing ravana rinslayer here and
saying she is a moon knight and then
presenting her to us in this way what it
looks like is this is where ravana
rinslayer starts this is where her
origin begins instead of it being in the
40th century she was just a person in
egypt and ended up becoming a host for
konshu as the first moon night or one of
the moon nights presumably the second
moon night after avengers 1 million and
she just kind of goes forward from there
but again things will be explained as
time effectively goes on because we'll
actually see different versions of her
in different points in time across this
story so it'll be a little murky to a
degree not gonna lie a little ambiguous
there but at the end of the day she
presents herself as a person that
wholeheartedly believes in the idea of
conscie and what ends up happening is
nathaniel kind of says i do not believe
in gods in my life of conquest i have
crushed countless divine skulls in my
hands but even before i saw fear in the
eyes of the god of thunder and yet he
recalls those thoughts by kang never
love and he says in that place my mind
ran clear the past the future like a
river of blood from my mind to king's
neurokinetic armor time and memory
coursed through my veins i swore that i
would be the hero she saw in me i swore
to tear him down and she says in the
shadow of a dead god i took my revenge
and cast it in iron and so what this
says and this isn't necessarily
something that's absolutely solidified
in the modern era what this says is that
this younger version of kang basically
becomes the first iron lad now i say
that as if there's more than one iron
light i mean i guess it technically
there kind of is but not necessarily the
reality here is that in the end it is
all king right so this kind of origin
still rings true right the origin of
kang but one of the things to know is
that in the old school or not really old
school but in the young avengers stories
that the idea of iron lad was basically
a younger version of kang that didn't
want to become king and did everything
he could not to become king but in the
end every origin of everybody stems from
kang in the 30th and 31st centuries and
so because of that they are all destined
to become king eventually immortus goes
on to become king iron lad goes on to
become king everybody originates from
kang because he was a guy that basically
went back in time and initially started
it all and that's why if you look at
characters like king the conqueror or
even like uh reverse flash eobard thawne
and dc comics the reason why they're
basically indestructible in the sense
that you can never truly kill them is
because they effectively exist
simultaneously at different points in
time and so because they exist at
different points in time they can always
reappear at any point in time so imagine
you for example traveled back to i don't
know like the first century right just
some arbitrary point in time uh you
exist in the first century but because
we have branch universe theory there's
also a reality or a timeline where you
never travel back in time and so if
somebody were to go to that point where
you quote unquote went back in time and
they stopped you the moment before you
did and they killed you then what that
would mean is you would still exist in
the first century you would still be
there instead there is a branch universe
that exists out there now where you died
before you could go back in time so you
could never truly kill that person it's
one of those things where in in marvel
and even dc comics once a person learns
the ability to travel through the time
stream the instant they make their first
attempt or their first travel through
time they can never truly be destroyed
now they can always just reappear at any
point in time so it's really kind of
murky and it's really it's very very
ambiguous and i know when it comes to
time travel it can be a little confusing
but it's essentially a way to unlock
immortality using technological means
but the results of this is that as iron
lad really the first time he becomes
this character he basically ends up
helping the forces of of moon knight and
this what seems to be this rebel faction
facing off against ramat hut and trying
to bring down his rule now the reality
of this and what's really really cool is
that in these various battles they're a
part of there is a larger force pulling
the strings when it comes to these
forces that are trying to destroy or
bring down kane to conquer we'll get to
them here in a second although i imagine
some of you guys have already guessed
who that person is one of the greatest
characters of all time
[Laughter]
whom i absolutely love uh but one of the
things to know is that as the these
battles are fought that it's really more
of a series of battles as part of a
continuous war and as you know battles
end and so in these bits of lolz there's
a very deep and personal connection
that's formed between nathaniel and
ravonna rinslayer and it's kind of
interesting because she asked the
question in the place that you come from
is this place remembered and he says in
the time that i come from everything is
remembered imperfectly and through the
lens of the victors perhaps but
remembered all the same that was the
problem when everything's been done
before you what can your life possibly
be worth but i knew i was destined for
more even before king came to visit me i
knew and the response to ravana is i
have never known a life without destiny
i remember nothing before it my parents
were the will of konshu and they have
long ago vanished into the sunlight of
my memory if they were ever there at all
and the response here is that nathaniel
asks did he give you your name your god
and her response is no my name has
always been but he did give me yours and
that's when she says like i was told you
were coming here but in this moment he
recalls the words that king had spoken
to him when he was effectively trying to
rid him of weakness and saying never
love lest you be conquered but the
thought of nathaniel here is but he knew
nothing of love i was absolutely sure he
was a creature of hate when you are
young it is so hard to see that one is
only born from the other that without
love to inspire it hate is simply just
rage anger can be conquered by calm but
like its pathetic cousin regret hatred
just feeds it makes one ruthless it
drives the preparation of armories and
the shattering of centuries it
intertwines with the power of a parasite
around the brainstem love makes one
blind as hatred makes one see and it is
in that way that we fell under his eye
what nathanael's really saying here is
that when it comes to the ideas of love
and hate they really are intertwined
kang hates the person he became because
he experienced love because he fell in
love with ravana rinslayer and he saw
that idea of love as the thing that made
him weak that rage is directionless rage
has no real drive or ambition it's a
thing that exists as a byproduct of
experiences things that have maybe
happened to you but it's not necessarily
born in love but love is is an intensely
positive emotion and i would argue the
most positive emotion hate can be born
out of love which drives you to the most
negative emotion the reality here is
that he sees kang as becoming the person
he did because he experienced love but
in his desire to refuse to become king
he embraces love he seeks love and in
fact that's where he and ravana
rinslayer effectively fall in love now
again this is why i say this new origin
of ravana rinse slayer is a little
ambiguous here because the answers she
gives nathaniel on her origin are cloak
and dagger at best right and it may just
be smoke and mirrors she's like well
i've always had my name maybe it's the
name that was given to me by my parents
but i don't really even know if my
parents existed anymore right their
memory the memory of them is basically
gone and it's one of those weird things
because you would think that for a
person her age which you know just going
on the way she's drawn looks to be maybe
in her late 20s early 30s she would very
definitely remember her parents but the
idea here is that potentially her
parents may have died and when she was
at a very young age in which case it may
be one of those things where her memory
just doesn't really recall a lot of her
parents because she was so young when
they died there's no definitive answers
given here but you could look at it from
a different perspective and say she's
very much like rama tut she basically
came here at some past point in time and
she came here from the future because of
all the different adventures in
escapades she'd gone on but at the end
of the day uh she's just fallen the same
path as rama tut she doesn't remember a
whole lot about herself but what goes on
is that once the two of them are
captured and they're brought before
ramatat that initially rama's hud
actually ends up blasting uh ravana
rinse slayer with what's known as the
ultra diode ray and it's basically a
weapon well used by kane the conqueror
is how he ensnared a lot of the people
under his service and basically forces
her into a position of of being a
subject right it takes away her
willpower and in fact that seemed to be
the way in which he was able to form his
initial higher counsel and then in turn
position himself as a god king now the
response of nathaniel is of course to
lash out one part because he's in love
with her and two because he knows that
rama tut is king from a different point
in time now remember as time would pass
kane the conqueror and ramu tut would
eventually become their own distinct
personalities but rama tut does remember
his his idea or remember him being king
at one point in time and so that's why
he he kind of recognizes nathaniel
richards to a degree in so far as like
iron lad different things like that but
he doesn't have any memory of this sort
of encounter taking place because it's
never happened before or at least it
doesn't seem to have happened before one
of the big issues is that king's entire
history is a time loop and so seemingly
this has happened before it's just for
whatever reason every time feels like
the first time which is kind of weird i
know it's we're not going to go into
that because it just seems wonky it just
seems really really meta and honestly
would just take too long to explain uh
but at the end of the day
rama tub really says like i have no
memory of this right a divergent
timeline perhaps some kind of a variant
or a new loop whatever it is what this
means is that killing you would no more
affect me than the destruction of an
alien son and the response to nathanael
is smart here he says but rama tut is a
footnote in our story barely even a
prologue you don't even know our true
name i would think very hard before you
execute me the throat you slit may very
well be your own that means kane the
conqueror will never come into existence
and if kane the conqueror never comes
into existence there's no one to come
back in time and to be you now the
reality here is that colin kelly is
jumping back and forth between a linear
timeline and branch universe theory the
reality here is based on marvel's branch
universe theory if ramat were to kill uh
basically iron lad it wouldn't make any
difference it would have no real
involvement in any real capacity
whatsoever it would just be a thing that
happens and that would basically be it
uh that's kind of how that branch
universe theory concept works in marvel
comics but at the end of the day what he
says is you know what you're absolutely
right here uh you know killing you is
too much of a risk however using you is
a great strategy because you're
technologically advanced you have access
to essentially all my resources and even
some of the resources that i don't have
access to so we'll turn you into a
servant instead of killing you and so by
blasting him he basically turns him into
what is in effect the first scarlet
centurion now one of the big differences
between this and comics as they were
originally written is that when cain the
conqueror was on his way back to his
time stream he did end up arriving in
the modern era due to a time storm and
encountered doctor doom and their first
encounter and somewhat inspired by
doctor doom's armor basically kane got
rid of the rama tut guys and then
basically started calling himself a
scarlet centurion of course again that
was covered in what was covered in a few
different places it was like avengers
annual number two god it was like
captain america annual number 11. and i
want to say it wasn't fantastic for
no it wasn't it was a what if story i
remember the exact issue of the what if
story i think was issue number 20. yeah
it was what if issue number 29 um that
all this stuff was basically explained
and and whatnot but the thing behind
this is that giving us this indication
as the first skull of centurion what it
does is it sets the stage for the idea
that in a lot of ways cain the conqueror
just kind of inspired himself to become
the people that he was but making
nathaniel into scholar centurion he ends
up leading the forces of king the
conqueror albeit against his will
against the force that is controlling
all these individuals out there that are
fighting against the rule of of ramatat
and trying to conquer his kingdom of
course all of them being led by
apocalypse which i love now this is one
of the things where colin kelly's
basically kind of blowing off the old
adventures of cyclops in phoenix which
is where you got the initial origin of
apocalypse where basically he was rising
to power around the same time that rama
tut was defeated and the way he's
depicted in this comic he's already in
possession of celestial technology that
hadn't happened yet in the old school
story so basically it's colin kelly kind
of rewriting the history of apocalypse
to a degree which is fine the origin of
apocalypse i mean it's there but i never
really took it as an absolute truth and
it's one of those things where anybody
could rewrite it in virtually any way
and it's fine if they did for the most
part people don't really care about
apocalypse
before he became apocalypse they care
about him after he became apocalypse
because that's when he got awesome right
so it's cool to see him leading this
force now of course with apocalypse at
what is in effect the height of his
power because once he achieved this
level his power never really increased
he was just at this state for seemingly
thousands of years before the modern era
but the thing about this is that at this
point in time he's wildly powerful and
wildly capable but in the end the battle
is a pretty severe and extreme battle
and so what nathaniel says it was is
that it was in those days that i first
knew war i learned the way a scream
sounds when it is someone's last and how
fear alone can stop a heartbeat even
before death love made me blind and so i
began to hate i saw the only path
forward my body was a prison my armor a
cage to escape king's power both needed
to be broken and he says and through the
pain i swore i will have revenge on king
i will have revenge on king and he's and
that's the thing he keeps saying to
motivate himself and that's the thing he
kept saying to remind himself now by the
time he gets back to the citadel of king
where king is basically operating that's
when he sees the fantastic four fighting
against kang and then ultimately pushing
him back to his timeline and of course
that's how his history kind of unfolds
the original scarlet centurion as we
initially saw him in the old fantastic
four comics and so on and so forth but
the reality here is he says that within
a day of ramatun's escape into the time
stream his kingdom fell to chaos that
apocalypse took all he wished and burned
the remnants no record of ravana
rinslayer like a footprint in the sands
of the desert she was scattered to time
i told myself a lie in those days none
are lost in the light of the moon but i
knew better than to believe it she was
as dead as the god she served but kang
was still alive and so that's why things
are a little murky here is because again
maybe ravana winslayer comes from the
future she went to the past she
basically forgot her own history and
believed she had always just existed
there and then became a moon knight it's
one of those things that we'll explore
as the story goes on but the final act
and basically trying to get back to his
time because in effect he doesn't really
have the same level of technology that
he used to have he's stuck in his
scarlet centurion suit is he goes to the
only person who has a level of power
that could get him through the time
stream he goes to apocalypse and he
simply says together we can destroy kang
the conqueror because that's one of the
things to understand apocalypse is on a
level of power to where somebody like
hank he understands the danger he poses
but he's not afraid of him so with that
being said guys we're going to bring
this to an end
thank you all for watching and i will
catch you all later
peace